hallo
herzlich willkommen in meine tagten welt
heute gibt es von mir eine ganz
besondere torte
ich werde nämlich eine show geraten
wickelte machen mit einer etwa creme die
torte haben sich viele schon gewünscht
ich habe bereits auf meinem blog mal
eine himbeere schokotorte gemacht und
diese wickeltechnik die eignet sich auch
super für von dann trocken
so könnt ihr nämlich eine zahnfüllung in
die torte machen und können die tore
später trotzdem mit von dante überdecken
normalerweise darf man das nicht weil
seine nicht in verbindung mit dem von
dort kommen da weiß ich sonst davon dann
aufgelöst und bei dieser wickeltechnik
habt ihr dieses problem ganz einfach und
ganz kreativ gelöst
es ist auch einfach so mal was ganz
anderes dass man nicht immer nur einfach
so normale tortenböden hat sondern dass
die torten würden dann aufrecht stehen
und man beim anschnitt am quasi ist doch
senkrechte trocken stückchen hat gefällt
mir besonders ganz gut die wickeltechnik
ist auch gar nicht schwer das zeige ich
euch jetzt gleich und mit dieser torte
habe ich mich bei den philadelphia
contest beworben machte jetzt gerade mit
und zwar so spielt wie hat die trocken
stars da kann man einfach ein rezept
einschicken und musste einfach hoffen
dass den zuschauern also euch gefällt
und ihr könnt da dann fleißig mit
herzchen punkte
das heißt wenn ihr mich unterstützen
wollt dann verlinke ich euch den link
zum einer torte hier unten in der
infobox und dann könnt ihr da für mich
abstimmungen
der contest läuft schon seit märz ich
habe jetzt halt erst vorgestern mit
gemacht deswegen haben die anderen jetzt
unseren großen vorsprung aber wenn ich
reichlich von euch unterstützung
bekommen habe ich vielleicht noch ganz
gute chancen
im moment habe ich knapp über 700
stimmen was ich echt schon gut finde
dafür dass die täter erst zwei tage im
internet ist und mal schauen wie weit
ich damit noch kommen so eine wickelt
orte ist natürlich etwas mehr aufwand
als eine normale torte und als grundlage
als grundplatte packe ich einen
mürbeteig ich werde es wieder den
nutella website machen weil es einfach
eine schokoladen wickelt heute sein soll
wenn ihr aber keine schokoriegel täter
machen wollt oder keine nutella website
könnt ihr einen ganz normalen mürbeteig
hersteller die rezepte dazu habe ich ja
bereits schon veröffentlicht zb bei
meinen keksen im kürbis burg da ist ein
ganz normaler website ich würde davon
nur einfach nur die hälfte nehmen und
das weglassen oder mein halbes ei geld
nehmen das könnt ihr schon einfach so
bisschen esslöffel wasser einrühren
denn die torte wird nur einen
durchmesser von 20 zentimetern haben und
die menge ist einfach auf diese größe
abgestimmt jetzt lange rede kurzer sinn
jetzt zeige ich euch erst einmal die
zutaten für den mürbeteig und zeigt euch
dann wie es weitergeht
für den mürbeteig boden braucht ihr 30
gramm butter dies beim ihr zimmer waren
so kann ich sehr besser verarbeiten
50 gramm nutella und 60 gramm mehr
diese zutaten kommen jetzt in meiner
branche
dann werden sie zu einem glatten teig
verknetet
sony geht nämlich einfach die hände dazu
die mutter doch noch ein bisschen zu
kalt
manchmal braucht er merkt einfach die
wärme von eurer hand um sich besser
verarbeiten zu lassen
wer ganz genau weißt dann klappt dieser
zeit wirklich wunderbare falls dazu
trocken ist gibt einfach noch ein
bisschen nutella mit rein und wenn er zu
feucht ist dann gebt ihr einfach ein
bisschen mehr nur mit rein
wie schon erwähnt werde ich meinen
kuchen in einer 20 zentimeter springform
backen ich nehme es wieder den bug
rahmen von blumer da kommt jetzt mein
tag rein und stehend drücke ich jetzt
einfach in die form
ungefähr gleichmäßig angedrückt ist
stelle ich ihn mit einer gabel mehrmals
sein
das verhindert einfach dass er blasen
wirft und statt durch danone eben wird
das macht man bei webtrekk gerade so
durch die löcher kann dann die luft nach
aussteigen
der 3 monats über flache und so wird der
teig jetzt bei 200 grad etwa vier
minuten gebacken
nach dem backen sieht dann so aus ich
sehe das jetzt einmal von dem heißen
raus und dann von hier voraussichtlich
am außenrum damit ich den rand entfernen
können
und am sichersten ist es jetzt ihr lasst
es einfach auf dem backpapier abkühlen
damit der teig einfach nicht bricht ihr
könnt jetzt die zeit nutzen während der
mob backt und könnt schon mal die garage
stellen
ich werde eine zart peter karrasch
machen und werde sie dieses mal weil ich
sehe weil ich die torte nicht mit
sondern über zähe etwas lockere machen
das heißt ich reduziere den schokoladen
anteil und nehmen dafür etwas mechanisch
vielleicht noch ganz kurz viele fragen
immer wegen dem verhältnis und mit der
menge und was sie für eine schokolade
nehmen sollen ich habe dazu bereits
eingangs video gemacht dann müsst ihr
euch einfach mal anschauen und den
passenden look beitrag dazu lesen und
zwar verändert sich das verhältnis von
schokolade und sahne
je nachdem welche schokolade ihr benutzt
wenn ich zum beispiel zartbitter
schokolade leben brauche ich weniger
schokolade im vergleich zu sahne und
wenn ich voll wie schokolade oder weiße
schokolade nehme brauche ich etwas mehr
schokolade weil einfach die schokolade
nicht so fest ist wie ein zarter
schokolade und damit dann später einfach
die konsistenz stimmt müsste das eben
individuell an
passen wenn ihr diese torte jetzt später
mit von dort über ziehen wollt welche
euch raten zahlt bitter schokolade und
sahne im verhältnis eins zu eins zu
nehmen das heißt beispielsweise 300
gramm schlagsahne und 300 gramm zahn
bitterschokolade da ich das jetzt aber
nicht mache und meine torte nicht mit
von dort also nicht mit zucker tag
eingekleidet wird werde ich jetzt 300
gramm schlagsahne leben und 200 gramm
steak mit der schokolade und wie die
garage gestellt wird zeige ich euch im
nächsten schritt für die garage verwende
ich jetzt 300 gramm schlagsahne und 200
gramm zahlt bitterschokolade die
schlagsahne habe ich jetzt hier schon
auf mein herz auf höchster stufe die
muss jetzt einmal aufkochen und in der
zeit kann ich schon mal die schokolade
auspacken und kann sie etwas kleiner
machen
ich hatte euch ja in meinem ganache
video bereits erklärt dass ich die
schokolade eigentlich gar nicht mal
klein hacken sondern sie nur noch so
klein und recht
es reicht auf jeden fall ihr können sie
natürlich auch im thermomix herstellen
die zubereitung davon seht ihr findet
ihr in meinem kanal stimmung
sobald die spanier dann auftaucht könnt
ihr sie vom herd unternehmen dann kommt
die schokolade mit rein schaut dass sie
komplett bedeckt ist und dann lasst ihr
das so etwa drei bis vier minuten stehen
nach ein paar minuten könnt ihr das
nochmal um gehören
schön auch am topfboden krachten
da sitzt dann nämlich die ganze
schokolade fest noch besser funktioniert
es natürlich mit einem tragschrauber und
damit die ganz schön homogen wird wird
sie einmal noch parieren
beim mixen aufpassen dass sie nicht so
viel luft einschlag gerade wenn ihr von
dann torten mit ghana bestreichen wollt
aber hier macht es jetzt nicht weil es
ja mehr als überzug für die fertige
torte dann dient ich fürchte jetzt
einmal um und lässt sie dann im
kühlschrank komplett abkühlen
damit ich sie später gleich verwenden
kann falls ihr zeit habt könnt ihr die
garage natürlich auch eine tag
vorzubereiten
das erspart euch einfach an diesem tag
mehr arbeit und etwas mehr zeit und die
galas kann man schön aus kühren dann
lasse ich sie wieder auf
zimmertemperatur bringen und könnte sie
dann schön aufschlagen und dann weiter
verwenden
während meine garage im kühlschrank
auskühlt mache ich schon einmal den
rührteig ich verwende dieses mal einen
rührteig mit öl und keine biskuitteig
weil ich finde dass biskuitteig einfach
schnell zu trocken wird und dem könnt
ihr einfach vorbeugen indem ihr das öl
benutzt und dabei dazu habe ich ja
bereits schon ein video gemacht wie man
diesen rührteig herstellt das war ganz
am anfang meiner torten zeit habe ich
das grundrezept für rührteig gemacht mit
öl
natürlich kann man rührteig auch mit
butter herstellen aber ich finde diese
variante etwas lockerer und etwas
feuchter und bevorzugt die eben deswegen
die menge ist natürlich optimal
angepasst an meine bug vorn
das heißt wenn ihr ein anderes blech
benutzt dann verwendet ihr trotzdem die
gleiche menge also wenn es so ungefähr
von der größe her stimmt bei mir passt
einfach ganz gut dass meine backform 32
cm breit ist und nach dem backen
schrumpft das irgendwie auf 30
zentimeter runter und ich kann dann
später schön gleichmäßige streifen
schneiden die alle gleichmäßig hoch und
dick sind und habe später so eben
weniger teig im überfluss jetzt zeige
ich erst einmal die zutaten für den
nudelteig und zeigt euch darf wie man
ihn herstellt und dann geht es weiter
für den rührteig braucht ihr vier eier
die sollten zimmertemperatur haben 160
gramm puderzucker 85 gramm
130 gramm mineralwasser 130 gramm mehl
30 g speisestärke 30 gramm kakao und
zwei teelöffel backpulver das sind 10
gramm also die zubereitung kennt ihr im
prinzip schon
zuerst werden die eier mit dem zucker
schaumig gerührt und dann kommen die
restlichen zutaten dazu und es ist
besonders wichtig dass die eier
zimmertemperatur haben so lassen sie
sich nämlich viel leichter aufschlagen
die lasse ich jetzt kurz verrühren
nach dem puderzucker mit dazu und lass
das ganze dann weiß schaumig aufschlagen
hier könnt ihr deutlich sehen wie viel
volumen jetzt die eier masse hat hier
vermisse ich jetzt kurz die trockenen
zutaten miteinander also mehrere
backpulver speisestärke und kaka und ich
verwende grundsätzlich immer bacco also
den bitten
da werde ich oft gefragt ob ich auch
trinker co verwende das benutze ich
nicht weil da einfach viel zu viel
zucker drin ist und das sind so viele
andere stoffe noch drin also lieber zum
backen immer nur bei kakao verwenden das
kurz miteinander verrühren
ihr könnt auch durch ein sieb streichen
jetzt kommt hier das öl rein da nämlich
geschmacksneutrale sonnenblumenöl daran
dass mineralwasser
da könnt ihr an stelle des wassers auch
einvernehmen
alica gibt noch mal einen ganz
besonderen geschmack und jetzt macht das
mehl und die ganzen trockenen zutaten
und dann wird es ganz kurz eingeführt
da muss man eventuell noch ein bisschen
nachhelfen
weil die trockenen zutaten richtung
boden absenken und sorgfältig unter
rühren und hier habe ich schon mal meine
backform vorbereitet es ist weder meint
sarah backblech mit backwaren
da hat etwa 32 auf 36 cm
ihr könnt es natürlich in jedem anderen
backblech auch backen oder in einem
anderen rahmen
ihr könnt den teig auf aromen zufügen
wie orangenschale herum roma roma wie
tamandl vanilla ob was er gerade lust
habt aber ich denke manchmal ist weniger
einfach mehr
der teig wird jetzt bei 175 grad etwa 20
minuten gebacken
ich werde auf jeden fall die stäbchen
probe machen und schauen dass er durch
ist achtet beim backen der teig platte
bitte darauf dass sie teilweise nicht zu
lang gebacken wird sonst wird sie
nämlich zu trocken und kann später beim
wickeln schneller reißen und brechen
das heißt lieber eine minute früher aus
dem ofen nehmen alles zu spät macht auf
jeden fall die stäbchen probe und sobald
da nichts mehr am stäbchen am
zahnstocher dranhängt könnt ihr die
tortenplatte rausnehmen
mein tag ist jetzt fertig da hat es doch
nur eine viertelstunde gebraucht da
müsst ihr wie gesagt selber schauen über
neuer teig fertig ist
ich werde jetzt vom fach krank lösen
und dann leg ich hier jetzt so ein
backpapier drauf halten gut zusammen
fest und stürzte es einmal da kann ich
nämlich schönes backpapier abziehen und
statt kuchen kann jetzt schön abkühlen
während die tortenplatte es abkühlt
könnt ihr schon mal was anderes
vorbereiten ihr müsst ein prima die
zwischenzeit nutzen
dann habt ihr nämlich später viel
weniger zeit verbraucht und zwar werde
ich jetzt in der zeit die dekoration
schon mal vorbereiten die creme kann ich
ja noch nicht vorbereiten weil dies
sonst auf die torten platte warten
müsste das heißt die mache ich erst
später wenn die tortenplatte kalt ist
damit man sie gleich verstreichen kann
und jetzt werde ich aber die deko
vorbereiten und zwar kommen als deko ein
paar erdbeeren auf die torte und ein
paar schoko momente die erdbeeren werde
ich jetzt mit schokolade überziehen und
damit weiße schokolade dekorieren und
die stoffe ornamente werde ich einfach
mit einem spritzbeutel spritzen und wie
das alles funktioniert zeige ich euch
jetzt
dazu nehme ich mir diese app bernd ich
vorhin weg gelegt habe die lasse ich
hier gut auf küchenkrepp abtropfen
die möchte ich nämlich mit schokolade
überziehen
hier habe ich darf wieder schokolade 100
gramm ich habe jetzt hier etwa 60 bis 70
gramm drin
hier sind 30 bis 40 gramm bei schokolade
ist es besonders wichtig dass die
temperiert wird das heißt einfach ihr
müsst sie vor kristallisieren damit die
schokolade später eben nicht grau
anläuft und einen schönen glanz hat
später bei zimmertemperatur auch immer
noch standhaft ist und fest und wenn man
sie bricht hat temperierte schokolade
auch einen schönen glatten bruch
jetzt gibt es dafür verschiedene
verfahren es gibt schokolade thermometer
mit dem kann man besonders exakt
arbeiten oder gearbeitet
einfach so dass man einen teil der
schokolade schmilzt und daneben einen
teil um geschmolzener schokolade mit
rein gibt und so die temperatur
angepasst natürlich ist diese methode
nicht ganz exakt aber für mich reicht
sie vielleicht werde ich mir in zukunft
mal so ein schoko thermometer zulegen
aber wie gesagt für den augenblick
reicht es so ich möchte damit auch keine
kunstfiguren oder so herstellen sondern
einfach kleine schokoladen ornamente
oder auch einfach meine torte mit
schokolade überziehen so dass den
schönen glanz hat und wie diese methode
funktioniert und wie ich das mache zeige
ich euch jetzt die schokolade werde ich
jetzt im wasserbad erwärmt
das ist sprich abgekochtes wasser
ihr solltet es generell nicht zu heiß
machen das heißt ihr braucht es nicht
auf dem herd stehen lassen sondern es
reicht mit dieser wärme und es macht man
generell so dass man zuerst nur zwei
drittel der schokolade erwärmt und das
restliche drittel erst mal extra lässt
das kommt nämlich dann später dazu um
die schokolade auf die richtige
temperatur zufrieden
wenn die schokolade dann komplett
geschmolzen ist
nehmt ihr sie aus dem wasser heraus dann
kommt hier jetzt die restliche
schokolade rein und steht jetzt mit der
restwärme geschmolzen
wenn sich diese schokolade dann komplett
aufgelöst hat sollte die schokolade
eigentlich die richtige temperatur haben
ihr könnt das ganze jetzt kontrollieren
indem ihr einfach einen löffel nehmt den
mit schokolade benetzt und standhafte
arbeitsfläche trocken hass und wenn die
schokolade dann nach etwa einer minute
anfängt fest zu werden schön glänzt und
kann den grauschleier hat dann ist die
schokolade richtig temperiert und kann
so verwendet werden
ich nehme jetzt einfach so eine
tortenplatte ihr könnt auch backpapier
nehmen habe ich aber jetzt da ich habe
jetzt ein bisschen palm ihn drauf
geschmiert und jetzt nehme ich mir meine
apps per ich möchte sie nicht komplett
damit eindecken und trug sie jetzt in
die schokolade das kurz abtropfen und
dann setze ich dir hier so drauf
so sehen dann die erdbeeren aus die
stelle ich jetzt so lange zur seite dass
sie schön fest werden können
das könnt ihr auch in den kühlschrank
stellen wann geht's schneller und mit
der restlichen schokolade werde ich
jetzt noch ein paar ornamente spritzen
für die dekoration der torte für die
ornamente nehme ich mir einfach einen
spritzbeutel die gibt es übrigens in
online-shops einfach mal nach
spritzbeutel googeln damit ich beide
hände frei hat ständig die wachen glas
und kommt schön die schokolade hier
eingeben
falls die schokolade zwischenzeitlich zu
kalt geworden ist einfach wieder kurz
aufs wasser bat stellen und die richtige
temperatur überprüfen und dann möglichst
ohne luft verschließen und dann schneide
ich dann ganz kleines loch ein damit ich
möglichst feine ornamente spritzen kann
das könnt ihr auf einer bank folie
machen oder auf dem backpapier dass ich
euch überlassen und dann einfach die
form spritzen die ihr wollt
natürlich hätte wie gut oder wie
schlecht ist es mit den ornamenten
klappt werde jetzt einfach so auf dem
bug rost geben und in den kühlschrank
stellen und später schaue ich mir dann
an ob sie schön fest geworden sind ob
sie aufheben
so sehen die app denn jetzt aus und ich
möchte jetzt noch mit weißer schokolade
dekorieren
jetzt habe ich hier wieder im wasserbad
und gibt da die weiße schokolade rhein
und die werde ich dann wenn sie
geschmolzen ist
in einen spritzbeutel füllen und stein
noch schöne weise muss da drauf spritzen
kalt und ich kann die frisch käsecreme
zu bereiten
falls ihr keine frischkäse möchtet oder
nicht mögt dann könnt ihr auch ganz
gerne magerquark benutzen oder sahne
quark
ihr könnt ricotta nehmen oder mascarpone
also da könnt ihr einfach alles benutzen
was er gerade da habt und statt der
erdbeeren könnt ihr auch himbeeren
verwenden oder johannisbeeren bromberg
was ihr einfach am liebsten mögt ich
finde dass die frisch käsecreme zehn
sehr gut dazu passt weil sie einfach
nicht so süß ist und es sollte auf jeden
fall mal ausprobieren wie schmeckt der
frischkäse nicht raus die creme schmeckt
einfach nicht so süß wie normale sahne
creme braucht 400 gramm davon dann nehme
ich etwa 50 gramm puderzucker das mache
ich einfach davon abhängig wie süß meine
erdbeeren sind
ich nehme 200 g schlagsahne und hier
habe ich 500 gramm erdbeeren
davon habe ich mir sechs stück für die
dekoration weggelegt noch schön mit dem
grünen dran
die lege ich jetzt weg und hier habe ich
noch etwa 350 bis 400 gramm etwa die
habe ich jetzt schon geputzt und den
grünen teil entfernt und zur bindung
nämlich keine gelatine sondern nehme
heute sein abfahrt ihr könnt natürlich
auch gelatine oder ackerte neben aber
diese stand up artist rein pflanzlich
und außerdem hat den vorteil dass die
creme gleich fest wird das heißt ihr
müsst nicht warten bis die creme gelehrt
zuerst werde ich jetzt die star steif
schlagen
dazu gebe ich sie komplett in einem rohr
welcher und schlagt sie einmal kurz auf
und dann jeweils nur etwas von diesem ab
hart rein damit die sahne einfach schön
steig wird und stark gebe ich jetzt zwei
teelöffel davon rein
und weil sich solange geschlagen bis sie
fest ist wenn die sahne fest ist stelle
ich sie so lange in den kühlschrank
dann kommt der frischkäse in eine andere
rührschüssel hier kommt noch der bruder
zu kommt rein
und wer möchte gibt da noch ein spritzer
zitronensaft rein um diesen käse
geschmack entgegen so ist es wird jetzt
ganz kurz verrührt
stelle ich kurz zur seite
dann werde ich meine apps verehren
pürieren
das mache ich heute in meinem mister x
die kommen da jetzt einfach mit rein
ziehe ich jetzt auch kurze einmal hier
gebe ich jetzt noch etwa fünf teelöffel
5 gehäufte teelöffel sein apartment
haben
wenn ich schon dabei bin kann ich es
auch schon mal die streifen für die
wickel traute schneiden und zwar ist
jetzt die breite der streifen die ihr
jetzt fest legt dann auch die höhe der
torte damit ich kleine reste habt
schneide ich das jetzt einfach in vier
gleich dicke stücke datei kann jetzt bei
mir etwa 30 cm hier also werde ich
siebel anhalt zentimeter breite streifen
schneiden
hier stehen lassen bis die creme fertig
bissig damit die torte befüllung kann
bevor es jetzt mit der creme weiter geht
lässt sich erst noch meinen lebtag auf
eine kuchen platte und da streiche ich
jetzt etwas von dieser frischkäse creme
drauf hier könnt ihr aber zum beispiel
auch etwa marmelade drauf schmieren
stelle ich noch mal zur seite
hier habe ich jetzt die sonne unter
jetzt nehme ich mir hier meine teig
streifen und meine creme und schmier die
creme auf die talk streifen
jetzt freue ich den ersten teil streifen
vorsichtig auf der bericht gerade etwas
und den setzt sich jetzt einfach mittig
auf die torte hier die ränder schön
andrücken
jetzt kommt der zweite streifen den
setze ich jetzt hier an
und schlägt ihn einmal außen rum also es
ist mit kleine fummelarbeit und es
erfordert ein bisschen übung bei mir hat
beim ersten mal auch nicht ganz geklappt
da ist ständig der teig gebrochen aber
wie ihr sehen könnt
kann man den schönen wieder zu recht
wiegen und jetzt setzt sich den nächsten
teil streifen hier an dass er hier
fortlaufend so eine spirale bildet
da brauche ich jetzt nicht mehr alles
das heißt ich trennmittel zweck
schön in form kommt nicht noch mehr
auseinander tisch legte jetzt eine
springform hand oder im treppenraum 1000
rom und klemmt schön fest da oben könnt
ihr alles schön glatt streichen
unterseite sieht es ganz so aus
falls eure torte jetzt nicht ganz eben
ist könnt ihr nun mit einem messer hier
ansetzen und einmal runter schneiden
daneben und so stelle ich sie jetzt für
etwa zwei stunden in den kühlschrank
hier habe ich die garage die hat er
jetzt etwa drei stunden im kühlschrank
und danach habe ich sie jetzt von einer
halben stunde aus dem kühlschrank
rausgenommen dass sie wieder ein
bisschen akklimatisiert die werde ich
jetzt kurz mit einem handrührgerät
aufschlagen
die ständig kurz zur sind jetzt die
torte sich das einmal so wie es ist
einen drehteller gebe etwas ganz auf
meine teig karte und jetzt werde ich die
torte mit der garage eindecken
falls ihr die torte mit von dort über 10
volt würde ich hier noch bis gut boden
backen und darüber legen dann wird das
ganze stabiler aber wenn ihr keine von
don't decke drüber gibt schon reichlich
staffel gedreht
die stelle ich jetzt mal so wie sie ist
kurz in den kühlschrank damit sie etwas
fest werden kann
unter nachhaltigste fertig streichen und
dekorieren
er stand schon fest ist könnt ihr die
torte schön dekorieren
so wie ich das jetzt mach ich sitzen und
vorschlag meiner seite
ihr könntet heute natürlich so
dekorieren wie ihr bord genauso wie auch
an den zutaten veränderungen variieren
wie ihr möchtet wie ich jetzt meine
torte choräle zeige ich euch jetzt
ich habe hier so ein paar schicke späne
gemacht die gebe ich mir einfach in die
mitte
dann kommen hier noch die erdbahn drauf
jetzt möchte ich noch ein bisschen weiße
schokolade silber
schoko momente in die mitte und dann ist
meine torte auch schon fertig ich hoffe
dieses rezept gefällt euch und ich hoffe
das video wird nicht alles so lange ich
würde mich natürlich auch sehr darüber
freuen wenn ihr noch bei diesem
philadelphia konnte ist für mich
abstimmt mir fehlen jetzt gerade noch
wie gesagt fast über 3000 stimmen
ja ich bin mal gespannt wie weit ich
damit komme und wetter gewinnt die
anderen torten gesehen auch ziemlich gut
aus die torte eignet sich natürlich auch
hervorragend für den muttertag da könnt
ihr dann die fn zum beispiel herzförmig
obendrauf anrichten
ihr könnt natürlich auch stopps der
wickeltechnik den teig einfach in
normalen backformen backen können zum
beispiel in der herzform backen und
daneben dementsprechend schön dekorieren
ich habe meine torte mit als seminar
genommen und habt es dort meinen
kollegen gegeben
und wie ich die torte angeschnitten habe
seht ihr jetzt im anschluss dann wünsche
ich euch auf jeden fall viel spaß beim
nachbacken falls ihr noch fragen habt
dürftig sind wir gerne stellen
ich werde jetzt auch bald mal ein frage
antwort video zu von dante machen da
könnt ihr auch schon mal die fragen
sammeln und dann werde ich einen post
erstellen und da alle fragen darunter
sammeln und diese euch dann in einem
anderen video beantworten
ich wünsche euch jetzt noch eine schöne
zeit ich wünsche euch ein schönes
wochenende und dann bis zum nächsten mal
tschüss
m